Я народився в місті Житомир.
У Житомирі жив на вулиці Космонавтів.
Зі самого дитинства я мріяв про космос,
про те, що моя робота буде пов'язана з космосом.
Я навчався у Великобританії як студент.
Закінчив Лондонську школу економіки,
Кембриджський університет
і там залишився працювати.
Я цього не планував.
Хотів повернутися в Україну,
щоб пізніше зробити PHD в Америці,
але так вийшло, що я почав
працювати в Великобританії.
Екосистема Британії трішки більше
підтримує підприємців.
Зокрема більше підтримує космічні проєкти.
Саме в Британії я відкрив офіс Spacebit,
і ми почали інвестувати гроші в космос.
Це були гроші, котрі я заробив
на екзиті свого бізнесу,
це була платіжна система.
Трішки схожа історія з Ілоном Маском,
коли він продав PayPal
і потім займався космосом.
Час, в котрому ми зараз,
має дуже великий потенціал щодо космосу.
Зараз у нас є Джозефф Безос,
Ілон Маск, Річард Бренсон,
але невеликі компанії теж мають потенціал.
Якщо щось робити, то зараз саме час.
Ресурси нашої планети вичерпні,
тому ми повинні дивитися в майбутнє та
в космос, де цих ресурсів трішки більше.
Я вірю, що люди матимуть виробництво
не тільки на Землі, а й у космосі.
І шкідливі виробництва
в майбутньому будуть у космосі.
Люди будуть подорожувати
в космос як туристи.
Це не буде щось таке особливе,
тобто це стане частиною екосистеми Землі.
Ми перша англійська місія на Місяць
і наразі запускаємо
й першу українську місію на Місяць.
Це початкова стадія програми «Артеміда».
На Місяць полетить не чоловік, а жінка.
Наша програма дослідницька.
Ми шукаємо, із чого складається місяць,
які радіаційні поля потенційно
там існують та багато іншого.
Це те місце, де люди будуть жити,
можливо, вже через 10–15 років.
Ми вивчаємо лавові печери для того,
щоб більше розуміти, чи можуть,
наприклад, там жити люди.
Такий експеримент дуже цікавий,
тому що цього ніхто не робив.
Закрити вхід до печери і зробити там атмосферу,
щоб вони [люди] могли там проживати.
З наукового погляду це також цікаво,
бо в ці печери мільярди років
нічого не потрапляло з космосу.
Тобто ми бачимо Місяць саме таким,
як він був декілька мільярдів років тому.
Місяцехід, котрий ми розробляємо,
має не колеса, а ноги.
Спочатку ми летимо на ракеті.
Коли ракета дає нам необхідний імпульс
і ми вже летимо до Місяця,
то летимо на так званому посадковому модулі.
Після того як цей апарат вже буде
на поверхні Місяця, ми маємо деплоєр,
котрий спустить робота на поверхню Місяця.
Він самостійно пересуватиметься поверхнею,
фотографуватиме, робитиме різні
наукові та комерційні вимірювання.
Датчик радіації, вироблений в Україні
разом з компанією «Екотест», цікавий тим,
що він може працювати у вакуумі
і при дуже різних температурах.
Це буде перше сучасне вимірювання
радіації на поверхні Місяця,
до котрої ми будемо мати доступ.
— Доброго дня!
— Добрий день.
Дуже важливо знати,
який саме рівень радіації буде
в тому чи іншому місці на Місяці.
В України є, на превеликий жаль,
така історія, як Чорнобиль, це трагедія.
Але також у нас є знання
щодо вимірювання радіації,
щодо того, як ми можемо жити з радіацією.
Це дуже цінно.
Не в багатьох країнах таке є.
І тому ми вирішили, що саме Україна
виготовлятиме сенсор щодо вимірювання
рівня випромінювання на поверхні Місяця.
Такий вигляд матиме прилад,
який буде інтегрований до нашого місяцеходу.
Щоб ви розуміли різницю
між цими детекторами в розмірі.
Це такий детектор професійний,
якого використовуватимуть на Землі.
А коли ми відправляємо щось на Місяць,
воно повинно бути малим.
Відправляти на Місяць дуже дорого.
Один кілограм коштує мільйон і двісті тисяч доларів.
Дуже цікаво, що саме завдяки такому
маленькому сенсору, як цей,
ми зможемо отримувати багато наукової інформації.
Ця наукова інформація буде дуже важлива
для майбутніх поселень на Місяці.
Коли полетять астронавти,
ми знатимемо, як їх захистити, що очікувати.
До Чорнобиля доїхали о пів на дванадцяту.
У Чорнобилі [були] десь до першої ночі.
Потім ми поїхали в Прип'ять.
І в Прип'яті я був з одним ліхтариком.
За мною закріпили дівчину, дуже безстрашну,
і ми ходили по Прип'яті.
Я тоді приїхав на своїй машині Jaguar.
Я навіть дверей не зачинив,
думав, ми тут подивимося трішки.
А вона мене повела...
Ми два кілометри йшли по Прип'яті вночі
з одним ліхтариком, без нічого.
Ось така безстрашна дівчина.
Подивились спочатку це [оглядове] колесо.
Потім пішли до стадіону, там якісь тваринки бігали.
— Вона йшла без ліхтарика?
— Так, я собі забрав.
І я був у  досить таких непоганих туфлях.
Я потім приїхав додому, помив їх, поставив
і подумав: «А яке ж там випромінювання?»
Потім узяв ваш прилад і поміряв.
Компанія «Екотест» займається
напрямом радіації уже понад 35 років.
І коли почули, що потрібен детектор на Місяці,
ми це сприйняли як виклик,
який повинні реалізувати.
Є засоби, які ми постачаємо
атомним електростанціям,
Міністерствам оборони.
Ми постачаємо як українським
замовникам, так і закордоном,
а тепер у нас з'являється
новий замовник — це Місяць.
Мабуть, не кожен українець
може похвалитись тим,
що він відправляє щось на Місяць.
Ми плануємо тестувати робота також у Чорнобилі,
бо в Чорнобилі є радіоактивне випромінювання,
воно і в космосі, і на Місяці.
На Місяці воно в 200 разів більше,
ніж, наприклад, у Києві чи у Львові.
І тому ми хочемо
протестувати робот в Чорнобилі,
щоб побачити, чи зможе він
витримувати великі дози радіації.
Я вважаю, що саме на перетині різних культур,
на перетині різних технологій
ми можемо зробити якісь цікаві винаходи,
можемо швидше розвивати те,
що ми робимо в якомусь напрямі.
Люди, спілкуючись і отримуючи
цей міжнародний досвід,
краще починають розуміти, як щось зробити,
як це зробити швидше.
Тобто це якось об'єднує різні таланти.
Розвиток космічної галузі в Україні має потенціал.
Зараз нам треба працювати над тим,
щоб нашу країну знали не тільки як країну,
де грають футбол, а країну
і високих технологій зокрема.
І ми одна з тих зв'язуючих ланок
між Україною і Британією, є і інші,
котрі це змінюють, змінюють постійно.
Це проєкт на майбутнє, це ті речі,
які реалізовуються з певним відчуттям.
Це робота, яку ми робимо для того,
щоб передати знання наступним поколінням.
Насправді Україна для мене відправна точка,
з якої я стартував як людина.
Я вважаю себе українцем, і це дуже важливо.
Ми дивимось на Україну
як на державу з дуже великим потенціалом:
потенціалом людей, історичним потенціалом
і, вірю, що потенціалом майбутнього також.